Sau khi tiếp thu có bảo cảo từ cơ đơn vị, cục hàng không viên năm đã thống nhất, quy định tạm ngừng tiếp thu,
hay thác tà tà tà tà tà tà các càng hàng không năm trong vùng anh rượn của báo trong ngày 20 mốt,
bằng ngày 20 2 tháng 20 năm, hay nghĩ khu trăm hay bế làm.
Theo đó, càng hàng không quốc tế vấn đồn từ 20 2 giờ ngày 20 mốt,
táng 20 năm, hay nghĩ khu trăm hay nghĩ khu trăm hay nghĩ khu trăm hay nghĩ làm.
Càng hàng không quốc tế cắt bí từ 20 2 giờ ngày 20 mốt,
táng 20 năm, hay nghĩ khu trăm hay nghĩ làm, đến 20 2 giờ ngày 20 2,
hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành không tế lợi bài và càng hàng không thỏ sân tiếp tục thật giỏi các bạn tin khi tự,
để sất được chình kế hoạch khai thác của hợp.
Đối với các hàng không, cục il cầu các hàng chủ động thông báo cho hành khách thông tin
được chình kế hoạch bai để có kế hoạch đi lại phụ hợp.
Đối với tổng công tý quần li bai Việt Nam, cục il cầu tập chung 1 trong 15 lực con người và tiếp bị bảo đàn công tắc
sự báo khi tự hàng không tại các càng hàng không, sinh bai để kì thời đưa ra các thông tin sự báo khi tự về anh vượn của báo.
Đối với các càng hàng không công tý quần li bai khu vực, cục il cầu tật chung 1 lực để thực hiện các biệt pháp
phòng trong báo đến hạt tân ký thời của càng và tổ bai trên sân đốt.
Đặc biệt liêu tình trạng của hệ thông thắt nước tại sân bai để bảo đàn tránh tình trạng
hợp nước sò mưa tò trong bà sau báo. Đông thơi chủ đậu phối hợp và thực hiện nghiêm tốt các phùng ăn phòng trong báo của chính quyền địa phương triển 2.
Cục hàng không Việt Nam cũng liều ý các đơn vị vẫn đề anh vượn của hoàn liều báo kẻng ngôi lớn
dạy có thể với ngập lụt tại các càng hàng không không bị anh vượn chức tiếp của máo.